[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here
today i'm going to explain an american
monster movie called the sand
spoilers ahead watch out and take
[Music]
care the movie starts with some
youngsters partying on a beach a
cameraman films everyone as they dance
make out and have fun a guy named mitch
makes everyone put their phones in a bag
so no one can take pictures of the wild
night and put them on the internet then
two guys vance and gilbert bring a ball
of gooey substance claiming that they've
found it in the water everyone is
disgusted but they do not think much of
it the scene abruptly cuts to the
following morning everyone has fallen
asleep
a girl named kaley is with mitch while
four of their friends namely shonda
jonah ronnie and vance are in a car
nearby kaylee wakes up first and is
looking around when she sees a bird on
the beach struggling to fly she assumes
that it is stuck but all of a sudden the
bird sinks into the sand a shocked
kaylee tries to warn everyone not to
step on the sand but when she turns
around she sees her other friend marsha
who was lying naked on a bench jump on
the sand
her feet get stuck and she cannot move
the group is confused and vance tries
running out to get her kaylee tries to
stop him but he doesn't listen he too
falls on the sand before he can reach
marsha and get stuck by now marsha is
nowhere to be seen the sand has
swallowed her completely
vance screams in pain and asks his
girlfriend ronnie to help him as vance
tries to lift his head he realizes his
skin and eye are being pulled out of his
head a horrified ronnie screams his name
when he sinks into the sand the group
starts brainstorming ideas on how this
could happen when they try to call
someone they realize their phones are in
the trunk of the car jonah tries to
start the car but its battery is dead
the group is completely stuck on the
beach kaylee then goes near the deck and
hovers her hand over the sand we see
white strings trying to reach her palm
from underneath the sand mitch is
surprised to see it too just then
another one of their friends named
gilbert wakes up stuck inside a trash
can he curses the guys for jamming him
into the bin after he passed out the
other night the group warns him not to
move gilbert is confused but obliges
when he hears that marsha and vance are
dead mitch and kaylee go inside and
jonah looks at them jealously kaylee and
jonah were in a relationship a short
while ago but she is hurt as jonah is
with shonda now shonda tries to console
jonah saying that kaylee finally found
someone for her a few hours pass but no
one comes looking for them kaylee finds
some sunscreen and passes it to those
outside gilbert is on the verge of
passing out because of the heat kaylee
then starts brainstorming how this could
have happened they look around and
finally realize that everyone else who
is at the party has been sucked into the
sand too
just then kaylee notices the gooey ball
from the other night near the water and
sees that it has hatched they figure
that it was an egg of some kind of
creature that lives under the sand it
has been eating people as its food since
it was just born yesterday the creature
must be small in size and have a shape
kaylee devises a plan to figure out how
large the creature is she gets sausages
and starts throwing them around to the
beach to see how big the creature is
gilbert sees a bird being sucked into
the sand and freaks out he finally
realizes everything his friends are
saying is true the others retaliate
against throwing sausages around
claiming that it is their only source of
food but kaylee doesn't stop the last
sausage doesn't get sucked in and the
group celebrates seeing there might be a
way out but they still have no way to
reach that far in the sand jonah then
gets in the back of their car and picks
up two surfboards he puts one on the
sand and jumps on top of it everyone is
delighted when he doesn't sink jonah
then makes his way to a bench nearby
just when he is about to step on it the
surfboard moves by itself
jonah almost falls to the ground and the
string from inside the sand gets into
his stomach he manages to save himself
but his stomach is hurt he finds a bag
full of food supplies on the bench he
accidentally drops a banana on the
ground but it doesn't sink
jonah hovers his hands over the ground
and figures out that the banana fell on
the part where they lit the bonfire last
night so the creature cannot come out
through fire or ash when he stands we
see the wounds in his stomach get worse
and pus starting to come out of it he
starts to freak out and kaylee calms him
down telling him to go through the bag
he passes sodas and water that he finds
in the bag to everyone while still
whimpering in pain his wounds get worse
by the second jonah then tries passing a
can to mitch but the pouches of pus on
his stomach start to break he cries in
pain and lies down on the bench the
surfboards on the ground are still
moving suggesting that the creature is
growing and developing kaley notices the
strings attaching to the car's tires
trying to move it they do not have much
time before the creature grows big
enough to swallow the whole car shonda
and ronnie try to get the phones from
the trunk ronnie offers to get on top of
the hood and try to open it she asks
shonda to give the letter she has
written in a diary to her mother in case
she dies and steps on the hood she is
about to open it but kaylee stops her
saying that the trunk will open wide and
make her fall into the sand kaylee gives
them a rescue hook so ronnie can hold on
to it she finally manages to open the
trunk just then a car drives to the
beach and honks at the group this
startles ronnie she accidentally closes
the trunk again her fingers get stuck in
it making her cry in pain mitch and
kaylee yell at the car to help them
inside the car is a beach patrol officer
he assumes that the group is on drugs
and doesn't take them seriously despite
kaylee yelling at him to stay inside his
car the man steps out of it the group is
surprised when he walks freely on the
beach a close-up of his feet shows us
that the strings cannot attach to his
shoes the officer goes near jonah and is
disgusted by his wounds he completely
ignores his pleas to help him still
assuming that the group is on drugs he
goes to talk to kaylee and insults her
and mitch for being reckless teenagers
he asks kaylee to step out and gets
angry when she disagrees he threatens to
use his pepper spray on them but when he
reaches to get it he accidentally drops
his keys on the sand the man then gets
stuck while trying to pick them up the
officer finally understands that the
group wasn't lying but cannot do
anything now kaylee advises him to use
the pepper spray on the strings that are
catching him the spray works and he
manages to free his hand but half of his
arm is gone he screams in pain and the
strings pull him down again
after he is completely sucked into the
sand kaley gets the pepper spray he had
dropped now mitch plans to use sandals
and towels wrapped on his feet to run
through the sand and get to the
officer's car he believes since the
officer's shoes resisted the creature
the sandals would too shonda throws the
towel at mitch but the railing breaks
when he tries to catch it mitch falls
onto the sand and is brutally eaten by
the creature kaley has had enough of the
creature she sees the fallen railing
moving on the ground and gets an idea
she breaks a part of the railing again
and hands it to shonda planning to use
it as a bridge later she then gets on
the deck and manages to jump on the car
as soon as she lands kaylee punches
shonda in the face for sleeping with her
boyfriend shonda doesn't mind and the
two help ronnie to get her fingers out
of the trunk jonah who has been on the
bench the whole time tells kaylee that
he loves her kaylee then tells him of
her plan she wants to use the railing as
a bridge to get to jonah and then bring
everyone to the officer's car
shonda gets the railing and places it on
the sand she walks carefully and manages
to reach jonah kaylee does the same the
three are safely at the bench when
ronnie walks towards them however the
strings latch onto her injured hand
making her fall kaylee tries saving her
with the help of pepper spray but it
only works for a second the creature
grabs ronnie into the sand shonda then
wraps her feet with a towel and a bag
and runs to the car she successfully
gets on its hood before the strings can
catch her gilbert cheers to celebrate
but not long after his bin starts
shaking his body is cut by the edge of
the trash can and the blood attracts the
creature the girls ask him to hold on
but the creature has gotten inside the
bin and is grabbing onto his legs
gilbert starts vomiting blood
soon several large pairs of limbs grab
him and drag him into the ground the
limbs then shake the car and make shonda
fall on the hood she falls unconscious
as kaylee yells at her to wake up
several hours pass and now it is night
time shonda finally regains
consciousness kaylee is still at the
bench with an injured jonah shonda
discovers a raft on the top of the
officer's car and uses it to get to the
bench the three successfully get to the
raft and to the vehicle shonda and jonah
are inside the car but before kaylee can
come in a massive glowing tentacle
attacks her the creature has grown to
its full potential now kaylee gets on
top of the car where she finds a gas can
she uses it to light the tentacle on
fire and gets inside the car everything
goes silent as kaylee and shonda realize
that jonah has died from his injuries
the girls hug each other and cry
mourning the loss of their friends it is
now the following morning a man knocks
on the car's windows waking the girls
they see that the monster is gone now
and they can walk on the sand the two
walk across the sand together
traumatized as the man calls for an
ambulance in a closing shot the creature
revealed as an enormous jellyfish is
seen in the water headed towards santa
monica pier
that was probably the most exhilarating
game of the flores lava that they ever
played
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching